bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour cette vidéo consacrée au thème
sahel entre opus est le propre de
l'homme
alors je dis le propre de l'homme parce
que c'est l'expression consacrée dans la
littérature on devrait dire normalement
le propre de l'humain pour éviter toute
forme de sexisme mais bon ça on revient
au même pour ce qu'on veut faire
à savoir discuter de la pertinence de la
bipédie pour la définition de ce qu'est
un fossile d'humains ou un fossile de
non humains parce qu'en effet tout
récemment il y a eu deux articles qui
sont sortis presque simultanément alors
ils sont pas réellement sorti il y en a
un qui est entré visualisation sur jonah
lomu human evolution qui a été écrit par
robert thomas chiarelli et son équipe et
y en a un autre qui a été écrit fin qui
est publié près publié en pré print et
qui sera un jour peut être ou pas
publiés dans nature mais pour l'instant
il n'a pas été retrouvé
mais les deux sont sortis et c'est
probablement pas une coïncidence puisque
les deux équipes se font se font
concurrence celle d'un côté de robert
thomas chiarelli et de l'autre celle de
franck guille qui est là d'ailleurs
l'équipe la plus la plus proche de
michel brunet mais michel brunet qui ne
fait curieusement pas partie des auteurs
de cette publie là mais bref
le fait est que on a ces deux articles
qui sont sortis quasiment simultanément
qui ont été rendues publiques quasiment
simultanément
est ce qu'il ya de marrant c'est qu'en
fait en étudiant la même chose
c'est-à-dire le fameux fémur de style
entre opus celui qui il y a deux ans
avait fait scandale puisque on sait
battre roberto macquarie avaient pointé
du doigt que ce fémur exister dans la
revue nature's il me semble en tout cas
dans une revue à comité de lecture très
fortement côté et ça avait fait scandale
parce que ça sous-entend des en gros que
l'équipe de france guy et de michel
brunet avec cachet le fémur peut-être
parce que ce fémur portée des caractères
de quadrupèdes ce qui sous-entendrait
que en fait sa une entrevue ce ne serait
pas à dominer en tout cas si on admet
que ce fémur appartient bien à sahel
entre eux plus et donc ces deux articles
qui attribue ce fémur à sahelanthropus
d'ailleurs
suggère en fait l'un que ce fémur
appartient à un quadrupède et l'autre
que ce fémur appartient à un bip est
donc l'un suggère que salle entre opus
est un quadrupède et n'est donc pas un
membre de la lignée humaine et l'autre
suggère que ça il entre aux puces
appartient bel et bien à la lignée
humaine puisque pour eux ce fémur
indique qu'il appartenait à un bipède
donc on a deux articles qui parlent
exactement du même spécimens du même
fossiles qu'ils analysent quasiment de
la même façon en utilisant ce qu'on
appelle l'épaisseur corticale alors
l'épaisseur corticale c est simple quand
vous faites une coupe à l'intérieur d'un
os vous avez une tranche qui est grosso
modo ronde comme ça et vous avez ce
qu'on appelle l'os corticale comme ceux
ci et vous avez ce qu'on appelle la
cavité médullaire au milieu et bien en
mesurant l'épaisseur de ce qu'on appelle
l'os corticale on peut arriver à
reconstituer
si un anneau minino eadsy hominoïdes un
grand singe était bipède ou pas et on
fait des mesures de cette épaisseur
corticale à plusieurs endroits il ya
certains endroits en fait où on s'attend
à ce que la charge imposée par la
bipédie sur le fémur augmente
l'épaisseur de l'os corticale pour le
renforcer et donc en partant du principe
que à certains endroits clés de l'os
l'épaisseur corticale va être renforcée
eh bien on peut faire des hypothèses sur
la station bipède ou non d'un individu
est donc en regardant la même chose ces
deux articles arrivent à deux
conclusions différentes
macquarie et son équipe suggère qu'il
était quadrupèdes ce fémur appartenait à
un quadrupède
alors que franck guille et son équipe
suggère que le
l'animal à qui appartenait ce fémur
était bipède
alors j'ai conscience qu'à ce niveau là
ça fait déjà appel à beaucoup de jargon
et notamment au niveau de la
classification donc on va déjà commencer
par faire un petit rappel de ce qu'est
celle entre opus et de quel est son
rapport avec l'évolution de la lignée
humaine ça il entre aux puces c'est donc
un grand singe un hominoïdes qui vivait
il y à sept millions d'années
on en a retrouvé plusieurs fossiles au
début des années 2000 donc c'est
l'équipe des gens qui travaillent à
poitiers qui ont découvert ces fossiles
au tchad et qu'ils l'ont nommé
sahelanthropus tchadensis le spécimen le
plus connu de sa haine entre opus
tchadienne sise que vous pouvez voir ici
c'est tout maille
il s'agit du crâne complet mais ce n'est
pas le seul fossiles qu'on a de sahel
entre opus mais c'est en tout cas le
plus le plus beau le mieux préservé et
ses faux cils de ça et landreau plus ils
ont été attribués à des eaux minini
c'est à dire ce qu'on appelle la lignée
humaine couramment sur la base de
plusieurs traits morphologiques de
plusieurs caractéristiques que je vais
vous lister dès maintenant
donc la première c'est l'usure apicale
des canines donc cette usure apicale des
canines
c'est un caractère important parce que
ça veut dire qu en fait contrairement
aux gorilles ou au chimpanzé par exemple
qui ont les canines inférieur qui passe
devant les canines supérieur donc si on
décide la mâchoire vue de devant ça vous
donne à peu près ça donc 4 incisive
voilà donc vous voyez que les canines
inférieur recouvre les canines supérieur
ça c'est chez les gorilles les
chimpanzés
ça veut dire que chez toumaï en fait on
avait les canines supérieur qui venait
par dessus ou en tous cas presque à la
pointe des canines inférieur et ça c'est
un caractère qu'on retrouve chez les
humains les humains n'ont pas les
canines de derrière les canines du
dessous qui passe devant les canines du
dessus toumaï aurait donc été plus
proche de nous de ce point de vue là le
deuxième caractère important de style
entre opus c'est la réduction des
canines donc les canines de sahel entre
opus
comparativement plus petit par rapport à
celle d'un gorille ou d'un chimpanzé ou
de n'importe quel autre grand singe
d'ailleurs donc ça c'est pareil c'est un
trait qu'on retrouve chez les hominidés
c'est un trait typiquement humain en est
enfin le dernier caractère c'est la
position en terro ventrale antero comme
antérieure et ventrale comme vers le
ventre du foramen magnum donc le foramen
magnum
c'est le trou qui permet le passage de
la moelle épinière dont chez un gorille
vous avez un crâne à peu près comme ça
et c'est très très laid mais vous
comprenez ce que vous êtes en train de
regarder
donc voici l'oeil voici le crâne chez un
gorille en fait le foramen vague magnum
va se situer à l'arrière du crâne
donc en position posters aux dorsales
postérieur et vers le sommet du crâne
alors que chez toumaï vous avez un crâne
que j'ai beaucoup mieux réussi et que je
viens de massacrer vous avez un crâne ou
le foramen magnum donc l'entrée de la
moelle épinière va se aussi trouvé va se
trouver plus en dessous donc ventrale et
plus vers l'avant que chez le gorille et
ça c'est dû à l'entrée de la moelle
épinière qui se fait par le dessous et
ça ça sous-entend que toumaï afin que
que ça et là entre opus mais bon ça se
voit sur le crâne de toumaï le spécimen
toumaï ça sous-entend que la moelle
épinière se trouvaient en dessous du
crâne et que donc il était en position
plus bipèdes que chez les autres grands
singes donc c'est trois traits là ce
sont des choses qu'on retrouve
typiquement chez l'être humain et la
dernière le dernier de ces caractères
celui là serait relié apparemment à la
bipédie donc déjà quand on se pose la
question du propre de l'homme
faut bien savoir une chose c'est que la
bipédie ça n'est qu'une partie de la
réponse
et surtout il faut insister sur la
combinaison de ces caractères
c'est à dire que l'usure apicale des
canines et la réduction des canines se
sont pas des caractères qu'on retrouve
que chez l'homme on les retrouve aussi
chez d'autres grands singes comme par
exemple le très célèbre gigan topic us
gigan topic est qu il a des canines
relativement réduite et qui s'usent par
la pointe et non pas par le vent comme
on le verrait si jamais les canines du
dessous passé sur les canines du dessus
donc ça c'est très très important de le
constater c'est que ces deux caractères
là si on s'arrête qu'à eux
on aurait aussi gigantesque us qui
appartiendraient à la lignée humaine
donc à ces deux caractères là s'ajoutent
la bipédie et la bipédie c'est pareil on
la retrouve pas que chez l'homme
parmi les grands singes la bipédie c'est
un caractère qui se trouve chez d'autres
grands singes ça se trouve par exemple
chez en tout cas supposément on pense
que un grand singe à nos minots ide qui
s'appelle danubius était plus ou moins
bipèdes et on pense aussi qu'il ya un
autre grand singe qui vient d'italie
donc danube yeux si nous vient d'europe
de l'est et on a un grand singe qui nous
vient d'italie qui s'appelle aurait au
pit et cus et lui il aurait eu aussi une
posture relativement bipèdes et on parle
d' une bipédie alors c'est souvent on
appelle ça la bipédie obligatoire mais
c'est enfin je veux dire obligatoire
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
est-ce que ce qu'on les force à être
bipèdes voilà c'est la grande question
non la bipédie obligatoire c'est très
très simple en fait c est ce que cette
bipédie est suffisamment commune dans le
mode de vie de l'animal pour qu'elle ait
déclenché des adaptations du squelette
est ce que cette bi pdi est visible sur
le squelette parce que nous il ya que ça
qui nous intéresse en tant que
paléontologues
est-ce que ça se voit sur le squelette
donc c'est pour ça qu'on parle de
bipédie obligatoire la bipédie
obligatoire c'est-à-dire la bipédie qui
se pratique tout le temps elles laissent
des adaptations des traces d'adaptation
sur le squelette une bipédie qui est
temporaire qui n'est pas obligatoire qui
a lieu qu'une fois de temps en temps
elle devrait normalement pas laisser
d'adaptation sur le squelette donc quand
on parle de bipédie et que soudainement
quelqu'un vous cliquer oui mais les
chimpanzés ils marchent debout des fois
on s'en fout on s'en fout ça laisse pas
de trace les chimpanzés ils marchent
debout des fois ils marchent pas debout
tout le temps donc ça laisse pas de
traces flagrante sur le squelette donc
c'est ça qu'il faut bien retenir avec
cette histoire de bipédie aussi c'est
que le propre de l'homme c'est certes
une bipédie mais c'est une bipédie qui
laisse des traces
on veut pas d'une vie bélie qui laisse
pas de trace et là en l'occurrence on
constate que pris individuellement ces
caractères bas ils valent rien ils
valent rien c'est la combinaison des
trois qui permet de dire qu'on est face
à un ennemi ni ni c'est la combinaison
des trois si vous prenez la bipédie tout
seul vous n'excluez pas certains autres
grands singes comme danubius et oreo
pittacus et qui sait peut-être une autre
espèce de grands singes qui marcherait
de qui marcherait suffisamment de façon
bipèdes
d'ailleurs la bipédie obligatoire ne
veut pas dire aussi qu'elle est
forcément au sol on peut parler aussi d'
une bipédie arboricole comme les orangs
outans par exemple les orangs outans se
balade très souvent debout dans les
arbres suspendu avec les bras mais leur
colonne vertébrale elle est verticale
donc il faut faire attention avec la
bipédie faut faire très très attention à
ne pas accorder trop de poids à cette
bipédie et c'est là qu'on va attaquer
ces deux articles qui viennent de sortir
ces deux études qui aboutissent donc à
des résultats radicalement opposées
l'étude de ma carélie et son équipe qui
disent que le fémur attribué à ça et
l'entrepôt était celui d'un quadrupède
alors que franck guillier son équipe hum
hum conclu que le fémur appartient le
même fémur appartient à un bipède et ce
en étudiant plus ou moins les mêmes
données
alors comment maintenant interpréter ces
résultats comme en face à une telle
contradiction entre deux équipes
d'experts est-ce qu'on peut interpréter
ces résultats
eh ben c'est là que le fait de pas
mettre trop de poids sur la bipédie
entre en jeu parce que effectivement ces
deux études ont à peu près les mêmes
défauts c'est celui de partir du
principe que la bipédie est le propre de
l'homme
bipèdes égale humain et on a vu tout à
l'heure que ce n'était pas forcément
vrai et en fait la question du propre de
l'homme
canepa philosophique elle est pas basé
sur l'autorité et c'est pas juste la
bipédie la réponse à la question quel
est le propre de l'homme
elle est excessivement simple lé
phylogénétique et on va passer beaucoup
de temps là-dessus parce que c'est très
très important de comprendre pourquoi la
question de la bipédie est
phylogénétique alors commençons déjà par
tracer une phylogénie de la lignée
humaine donc ce qu'on appelle les eaux
minini alors pour s'intéresser à la
phylogénie des homininés on va regarder
dans la littérature et voici par exemple
une fille le génie qui a été publié très
récemment une phylogénie des homininés
qui a été publié il ya seulement
quelques semaines
dans un article qui s'intéressait à part
entre opus donc un nominé qui est déjà
relativement dérivés comparé à toumaï
est donc cette phylogénie des homininés
vous voyez quelle place ça il entre aux
puces à la base à la base de l'arbre et
pour autant que je sache
et pour autant que la littérature
publiée a pu faire tourner d analyse
phylogénétique incluant sahel entre opus
sahel entre eux puce n'a jamais été
placée ailleurs dans une analyse
phylogénétique que à la base des
homininés on n'a jamais retrouvé ça elle
entre aux puces plus proche des gorille
plus proche des chimpanzés ou quelque
part entre les trois entre un chapeau et
gorille et humain donc il ya jamais eu
une analyse qui ont fait de toumaï autre
chose que un membre d ominique un membre
de la lignée humaine
alors évidemment vous allez certainement
posé la question mais là l'hypothèse du
gorille l'hypothèse de la gorille est
d'ailleurs alors l'hypothèse de la
gorille est j'en ai déjà parlé dans une
autre vidéo
en long en large et en travers mais pour
la résumer simplement l'hypothèse de la
gorille est suggère que certains des
caractères et notamment la réduction des
canines et l'usure apicale des canines
qu'on retrouve chez sahel entre opus
sont en fait des caractéristiques de
femelles et c'est vrai que chez les
grands singes notamment les gorilles les
chimpanzés
quand on est une femelle on a des
petites canine et ses petites canine
peuvent avoir une usure apicale oui mais
ça elle entre aux puces et quand on
regarde notamment le crâne de toumaï
sahelanthropus il ad énormes pour les
suces orbitaire et il a une petite crête
sagittale donc si vous regardez le crâne
de toumaï de façon légèrement oblique
comme il est comme il est souvent
présenté
vous avez ici les deux orbites vous avez
ici les normes bourrelet sus orbitaire
vous avez ici la mâchoire qui vient en
dessous l'arcade jus galles ici donc là
vous auriez le nez et là au dessus vous
avez un petit front fuyant très typique
des homininés bazot un petit front
fuyant comme ça et là vous avez ce qu'on
appelle la crête sagittale donc salle à
cette petite crête là on la retrouve
aussi chez les gorilles et elle est plus
développée chez lego rimal que chez les
gorilles femelles et elle est quand même
relativement bien développée chez toumaï
même si elle n'est pas super super bien
préservés on la voit quand même pour ces
deux caractères là le taurus supra
orbitaire qui est très développé et la
crète sagittale on pense que c'était un
mal et donc le fait d'avoir des petites
canine est très significatif si on est
face à un mal et qu'il a des petites
canine
c'est donc très très significatif je
suis un mâle au mini et j'ai des toutes
petites canine
donc est-ce que ça elle entre aux puces
a pu être une gorille est la réponse est
probablement pas en tout cas le curseur
de probabilité est très nettement du
côté non pour l'instant halde en l'état
actuel des connaissances on peut pas
dire que ça l entreprise soit un bon
candidat pour être une gorille est donc
jusqu'à présent ça il entre aux puces
c'est à nos mini et on l'a jamais
trouver ailleurs
donc c'est parti pour la reconstruction
de l'arbre phylogénétique donc on va
faire une version très simplifiée de
l'arbre phylogénétique des homininés on
va placer ici homo sapiens on va
commencer par nous parce que c'est quand
même le mini n'est qu'on connaît le
mieux
homo sapiens on va le placer à côté de
homo erectus qui est un autre mini n'est
que nous connaissons relativement bien
donc ils sont proches parents ensuite le
plus proche parent de ces deux homininés
ça va être australopithecus ça peut être
n'importe quel australopithèques us
on ne va pas discuter de la possible
paraphilie d'australopithèques us pour
ceux qui connaissent le mot paraffine
éthiques
on va laisser ça de côté pour l'instant
donc australopithecus australopithecus
est donc en groupe frère de tout ça donc
le plus proche parent du groupe dans
lequel on a au mot et australopithecus
on va placer hardy pitt et cus et en
groupe frère de tout ça on va avoir
or or in et en groupe frère de tout ça
on va avoir sa elle entre aux puces est
généralement ce qu'on aime bien faire
dans les phylogénie d'homininés c'est
ceci à savoir un grand trait qui remonte
tout en haut jusqu'au japon faisait
alors maintenant la question du propre
de l'homme où on va trouver le propre de
l'homme dans un arbre phylogénétique
comme ça le propre de ça dépend déjà de
votre définition de l'homme
si votre définition de l'homme c'est
homo sapiens alors le propre de l'homme
ça va être tous les caractères
anatomiques visible sur le squelette en
tout cas d'un point de vue
paléontologique mais ça peut être des
caractères génétiques si vous êtes
généticien tous les caractères
anatomiques qui se retrouvent ici sur
cette branche
alors ces caractères qu'est ce que ça va
être ça va être le petit menton
proéminent sur la mâchoire inférieure
ça va être le front
verticale et non plus fuyant et ça va
être l'absence de bourrelets sus
orbitaire de taurus sus orbitaire donc
ça par exemple ce sont des caractères
qu'on peut qualifier comme étant le
propre de l'homme si on s'occupe que
d'homo sapiens maintenant si on s'occupe
du genre homo si on considère que le
propre de l'homme c'est censé être le
propre du genre homo c'est quand même de
là que vient le mot sommes humains donc
ce sera les caractères qu'on retrouve
ici les caractères qu'on a en commun
avec homo erectus alors au moins
effectué sur cette version simplifiée de
l'arbre homo habilis et au monal ai dit
si on utilise une version plus
développées de ce même arbre mais en
tout cas et même homo floresiensis alors
du coup si on rajoute homo floresiensis
il ya plus beaucoup de caractère
notamment il ya on perd la taille du
cerveau avoir un gros cerveau ce ne
serait plus le propre de l'homme par
contre avoir des pousses du pied non
opposable donc avoir des gros orteil non
opposable là par contre c'est le propre
de l'homme donc vous voyez là comme je
disais tout à l'heure la réponse elle
est très simple c'est quoi le propre de
l'homme tant qu'on a un arbre
phylogénétique pour céder et ici bas
nous on est intéressé par la question du
propre des homininés du coup donc le
propre des eaux mini se sont tous les
caractères qu'on retrouve ici et qui
inclut sahel entre opus et qui exclut
les chimpanzés
donc si on considère ça elle entre aux
puces comme étant un ami ni ni comme
c'est le cas dans toutes les
philosophies qui ont été faites jusqu'à
présent
eh bien on a que là l'usure apicale des
canines
c'est le propre de l'homme additionné à
la réduction de la taille des canines
ça aussi c'est le propre de l'homme
additionné à la position ventrale du
foramen magnum donc usure apicale
réduction des canines foramen magnum en
position en terro ventrale ça l'addition
de ces trois caractères là c'est le
propre de l'homme
c'est bien l'addition c'est la
combinaison de ces troubles
trois caractères là qui est le propre de
l'homme maintenant si on prend les
résultats des ceux de ces deux études
prenons d'abord les résultats
de robert thomas chiarelli et son équipe
que je vais représenter en rouge sur mon
arbre donc ces résultats c'est que le
fémur attribué à sahel entre opus n'est
pas celui d'habib aide
donc si je place ça sur mon arbre ça
veut dire que la bipédie a évolué ici
donc je vais dessiner une sorte de fémur
ça voilà ici
est-ce que cela élimine immédiatement la
présence de ces caractères qui
soutiennent cette branche de l'arbre
la réponse est non la réponse est non
alors vous pourriez objecter que bah oui
mais du coup on a double apparition de
la bipédie donc ces deux caractères là
en fait ils sont pas totalement
indépendants ils dépendent tous les deux
de la même bipédie donc la position du
foramen magnum et la morphologie du
fémur
certes mais ce serait pas la première
fois qu'on voit des caractères liés à la
bipédie évoluer indépendamment en
réalité l'histoire de l'évolution
humaine
elle est faite que de ça de caractère
liés à la bipédie qui évolue
complètement indépendamment les uns des
autres
donc par exemple je le disais tout à
l'heure le pouce opposable du pied qui
disparaît là et ici chez
australopithèques us
on a les bras qui deviennent aussi long
que les jambes ce qui n'est pas le cas
de chez ardipithecus chez ardipithecus
les bras sont plus longs que les jambes
et on a notamment une bp dit déjà
temporaire chez le chimpanzé donc
supposément déjà une bipédie temporaire
chez l'ancêtre commun du chimpanzé et
des êtres humains donc la bipédie c'est
pas quelque chose qui arrive est comme
ça c'est quelque chose qui arrive est
graduellement et l'adaptation du corps
des eaux minini à la bipédie elle s'est
pas fait en une fois et maintenant si on
suit l'autre conclusion celle de franck
guillier de son équipe
eh ben on a une apparition donc du fémur
bipèdes des cet endroit là et ça ce
serait assez intéressant puisque ça
rajoute finalement au propre de l'homme
ça rajoute des caractères au propre de
l'homme à savoir non seulement le crâne
est adapté à la bipédie mais aussi le
fémur qui est adapté à la bipédie alors
après vous pourriez vous dire que avoir
le crâne qui s'adapte
oa la bipédie avant le fémur ça peut
sembler bizarre et là on en revient au
fameux argument d'autorité
si vous si vous pensez par vous même que
un fémur et forcé doit forcément
s'adapter à la bipédie avant le crâne
bas vous avez vous avez peut-être raison
mais vous avez peut-être aussi tort je
vous rappelle qu'il existe aussi une
bipédie arboricole et la bipédie
arboricole elle cède beaucoup des mains
les orangs outans aujourd'hui qui
pratiquent la bipédie arboricole il cède
beaucoup de leurs mains donc le poids
face à la pression de sélection pour que
le fémur s'adapte elle est quand même
moindre parce que la pression physique
sur le fémur
pendant cette bipédie elle est compensée
par l'utilisation de l'abrogation
donc voilà on peut faire des hypothèses
pour expliquer pourquoi le crâne
s'adapterait avant le fémur c'est pas un
problème ça mais faut faire ces
hypothèses après avoir constaté la
distribution des caractères sur l'arbre
pas avant et le problème c'est qu'aucune
de ces deux études ne propose d'arbres
phylogénétique pour discuter ces
caractères et c'est pour ça que
personnellement moi je suspendrai mon
jugement donc je fais pas cette vidéo
pour casser des des spécialistes qui
sont plus spécialistes que moi dans leur
sujet j'ai aucune autorité pour
contester leurs conclusions
s'il y en a un qui dit que le fémur 7
fémur d'habib est très bien et si
l'autre dit que c'est le fémur d'un
quadrupède algérien pour le contredire
non plus je ne peux pas dire lequel des
deux a raison et le cas la torre par
contre ce que je peux ce que je peux
savoir grâce à l'arbre phylogénétique
sait comment la distribution de ces
caractères influe sur la position
phylogénétique de toumaï et rajouter un
fémur dans l'équation ça ne change rien
donc si sahelanthropus était déjà un
home in basé sur ces trois caractères en
rajouter un ne change rien en rajouter
ou ne pas en rajouter un ne change rien
alors que faut-il retenir de cette vidéo
sahel entre eux puce bipèdes un bipède
humain pas humain et bah c'est très
simple en fait il faut réfléchir à
partir de l'arbre le ce qui va définir
l'humain c'est pas ce qui se passe chez
sahel entre opus c'est ce qui se passe à
la racine de l'arbre donc vous prenez
tout
homininés et vous regardez ce qui se
passe à la racine est ce qui se trouve à
la racine les caractères qui se trouve à
la racine c'est ça qui va vous définir
le propre de l'homme
et si la bipédie fait partie de ces
caractères alors ce sera un caractère
pertinent ou pas mais comme je les dis
il ne faut pas attribuer trop de poids à
la bipédie déjà parce que la bipédie
c'est un seul caractère parmi tant
d'autres donc parmi tous les caractères
que vous retrouverez à la base de
l'arbre de deux la bipédie savent se
décompose en plusieurs événements le
comme je l ai dit tout à l'heure la
bipédie elle évolue graduellement tout
au long de l'évolution humaine
il ya plein d'adaptation à la bipédie
qui se sont développées tout le long de
l'évolution humaine
donc ce n'est pas un événement ce la
bipédie ce n'est pas aussi simple que
avance n'était pas là et maintenant
c'est là la bipédie ça a été un très
très long processus qui s'est décomposé
et qui a essaimé des caractères hausse
théologiques tout le long de cet arbre
et en plus et ben ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que quel que soit
l'endroit où apparaît la bipédie c'est
pas ça qui fait le plus mal c'est pas ça
qui fait le les homininés notamment si
vous placez la bipédie avant l'origine
des humains enfin des eaux min et que
vous la placez chez l'ancêtre en commun
des chimpanzés et des eaux minini comme
le veut la théorie de la bipédie
ancestrale donc si jamais un jour on
découvre des fossiles de chimpanzés qui
était définitivement bipèdes par exemple
des ancêtres de chimpanzés bipèdes et
ben ça voudra dire que l'ancêtre en
commun des chimpanzés et des homininés
était bipède et sa vedette à dire que la
bipédie ne définit plus l'être humain
mais ce sera pas embêtant pour autant
puisque on aura toujours des caractères
ici à la base des êtres humains qui
unissent les êtres humains donc ça
voudra juste dire que le propre de
l'homme le propre des homininés ne sera
plus défini par la bipédie ne sera et
qu'il n'est déjà pas défini par la
bipédie c'est aussi ça que j'essaie
aussi de 5g essayer de vous convaincre
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il ya plein
d'autres caractères ici n'a pas que la
bipédie et puis si vous tenez à insister
vraiment à faire de la bipédie le propre
de l'homme je suis désolé mais ça veut
dire que les chimpanzés ne sont plus des
hommes ça voudra dire que votre
classification elle ne sert plus à rien
donc maintenant si on suit l'hypothèse
de robert thomas chiarelli et de son
équipe qui place la bipédie après ça il
entre aux puces donc qui fonde sa il
entre aux puces un zombie
peine en admettant qu' on exclu qu'on
oublie totalement à propos de la
position du forum et de magnum on dit la
bipédie ses oraux rin et les autres mini
né à l'exclusion de sahel entre opus
qu'est ce que ça nous donne est-ce que
ça exclut forcément ça et l'entreprise
des homininés bas la réponse est non la
réponse est non parce qu'on ne fait pas
de classification basée sur des
caractère primitif
on ne fait pas de classification basée
sur des absences de caractère sur des
noms quelque chose donc la non bipédie
ne fait pas de sartre opus un nom de
mini ni pour la même raison que les
arbres ne sont pas des invertébrés parce
qu'ils n'ont pas de vertèbres la non
vertèbres ne fait pas l'invertébré la
vertèbre c'est quelque chose qui a paru
chez un ancêtre en commun celui des
vertébrés
mais c'est pas quelque chose qui a
disparu celle ancêtres en commun de tous
qui n'a pas de vertèbres et bien là
c'est pareil
l'absence de bp dit c'est pas forcément
un indicateur de parenté donc voilà
c'est tout pour cette petite vidéo de
mise au point à propos de la sortie de
ces deux articles de la sortie prochaine
de ces deux articles alors évidemment
comme je les dis ces articles ne sont
pas encore sortis mais quand ils seront
sortis
je suis à peu près sûr qu'il va y avoir
de grands débats sur sahel entre opus
etait-il bipèdes ou non d'autant que
comme je l'aï dit il ya deux articles
aux conclusions radicalement opposées
donc vous pouvez être à peu près certain
qu'il ya deux camps qui vont se
structurer et qui vont s'échanger des
pics vous vous allez avoir grâce à cette
vidéo un point de vue qui est le point
de vue de la phylogénie et qui vous
montrent que la bipédie ce n'est pas
tout petit rajout en cours de montage
parce que je trouvais que ma conclusion
là il veut passer complètement à côté de
ce qui était réellement le message
important de cette vidéo et qui est qu
on n'est pas censé décider a priori de
quel caractère vont être importants dans
une classification quand bien même on
parle d'évolution humaine et quand bien
même on parlerait de la bipédie ce n'est
pas une décision à prendre a priori
décidé arbitrairement
quel va être le caractère le plus
important d'une classification c'est
quelque chose que faisait l'ine c'est
des choses qu'on a fait jusqu'au milieu
du 20e siècle mais c'est des choses
qu'on ne devrait plus faire aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on a des outils puissants à
base de statistiques et de méthodes
probabilistic qui permettent de dessiner
des arbres phylogénétiques qui nous
permettent de nous
et à prendre ses décisions donc c'est
des décisions qui devraient être prises
après qu'une phylogénie est été
construites et non pas avant donc le
gros message de cette vidéo c'est que
l'importance de la bipédie dans la
classification de sa haine entre opus ne
devrait pas être décidées a priori mais
d'après une phylogénie donc l'arbre
phylogénétique c'est la clé pour ne pas
se laisser embrouiller dans le débat à
venir
donc j'espère que ça vous aidera et je
vous dis à très bientôt sur notre chaîne